this one comes from Facebook and it's
Heidi Meyers and Heidi would like to
know why aren't there any more outbreaks
billions still live in poor sanitation
in cramped quarters cheek-to-cheek with
newcomers from lightly traveled areas of
bush meat is still eaten by many and
transportation is even faster than it
ever was it is due to vigilance I'm
sorry is it due to vigilance or are the
disease's evolving into endemic
conditions faster than they used to yeah
her first sentence was why aren't there
any more outbreaks that is incorrect
well I think she means pandemics that is
incorrect okay we just have been
battling in the last four or five months
but was we
disease fighters
you guys are like the Justice League of
the fiber so good well that's what Dan
Brown says yeah so we've been fighting
to one is called
sadly h7n9 it's a form of influenza that
emerged in China seemingly out of
nowhere really why do we always blame
other countries for the start of
influenza and we're the one who is the
one that might has America written all
over it do we call it something else
that would have been the h1n1
why do we call it the the United States
virus well it was American swine oh
really was that dilemonade well American
swine sounds like a cool new
erupt going so the H 7 & 9 is an
influenza that emerged in first seen in
Shanghai and it was coincident with in
January 20,000 pig carcasses slugging
through the Wang poo River the central
river of downtown Shanghai I'd be like
having 20,000 dead pigs come down the
East River so these two Shanghai would
be an environmental improvement upon the
East
just sayin so these are we're in the
question by the questioner referring to
squalid areas where their water Shanghai
Shanghai is pretty a truly advanced
modern super hyper modern city
twenty-three million people and all of a
sudden along comes a virus the
connection to the dead pigs never
established very controversial inside
China because pork is the number one
protein source for most Chinese so we're
not going to talk about you know what
might be in your pork butt and that
virus spread all the way up to Beijing
and all the way down close to Hong Kong
and caused havoc and seems to have
stopped because they shut down the live
animal markets however it also stopped
coincident with what is weather-wise
usually the end of flu season so we're
all very anxiously waiting for next fall
is this going to come back with ferocity
that one had a very high kill rate it
was around 25 26 percent of the people
who got it guys holy moly but that's not
as bad as the one we're now very worried
Lee watching which has another
unfortunate dubbing it's MERS Co V which
it stands for Middle Eastern respiratory
syndrome coronavirus
Oh God okay right but let's just call it
MERS for the sake of argument this is a
virus that is genetically very close
cousin to SARS remember that from 2003
when I read to 31 countries
still have my mask from the sorry
sport he never never gives up the old
antiquated devices so I won't go there
so this MERS virus emerged it seems to
be from Saudi Arabia it seems to have
originated possibly in the al-hasa
region which is an oasis in the desert
near bahrain in the eastern part of
Saudi Arabia so once again not squalid
areas no and a lot of the cases were in
downtown Riyadh urban big city the major
you know for entry for people flying in
and out of Saudi Arabia what has people
very concerned and there's an emergency
summit underway right now in Cairo a
call by wh Oh what has the World Health
Organization it has the whole Middle
East freaked out is that aura which
kicks off Ramadan yes is just a couple
weeks away and then in early October you
have the Hajj on both occasions you have
mass Islamic pilgrimages to Saudi Arabia
so if you've got a respiratory virus
that is
transmissible Wow by their hair and by
close contact like kissing like being in
the Hajj elbow-to-elbow going around the
tomb of Mohammed repeatedly with
millions of people then you have
potential for serious spread man that's
a party I don't want to go to yeah well
and and the problem is the Hajj has a
long history of being a time for disease
to spread
and it is the responsibility of the
Saudi state to ensure that this
religious pilgrimage is safe otherwise
it becomes a communal bath that everyone
takes in in disease sorry for hiding
questions quality conditions not all
that bad
don't worry that not the problem I don't
think that's what Muhammad's tomb I
think it there's a stone inside of
there's no sacred stone you're right yes
correct